but the next category is one of my
favorites actually yeah the best
trash taste animated oh and god knows
we've got
way too many to choose yeah we've got a
lot of animators there's a lot of really
good channels of them
honestly like i don't think anybody
expect the animations to be made yeah
we're so flattered and obviously
we are really so many of the animations
are so good they're so good
fantastic please keep them coming we
always share them on
our channel as well yeah but yeah let's
look at the nominations so we got the
great burger debate uh
some of the hardest parts were actually
picking which video to put on
this nomination are these videos yeah oh
yeah no i just show the clip yeah show
them
off the best part of a hamburger it's
like the pizza thing dude it's the city
energy
it's all the accumulation of the tastes
that come together
and they strike slightly moderate
strikes slightly more
nice it's so good i love as well how he
makes all of us like
really look like how we are yeah yeah
it's so perfect
and then we have the uh judith the
kaiser trash taste collapse
yeah i don't think we can play this
audio can we we can show some of this
yeah yeah
out loud now but in the video we have to
yeah we have to censor it unfortunately
[Music]
god the amount of references they were
able to cram in such a short
time span is like incredible in this one
honestly all of these honestly are just
crammed with references
yeah yeah i mean if we're talking about
references oh this one
this one is [ __ ] amazing i just
imagined you in the [ __ ] morning
every every morning
okay like in the mirror god you got you
got
absolutely fantastic and then we got uh
mori calliope can't say the f word
this one made its rounds because of the
hololive subreddit yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
i love that one honestly i can't even
choose a favorite
i mean we can only have five nominees
for this one but honestly
every single animator we've received has
been [ __ ] fantastic so please
we really love your work and we love
watching them as well yeah absolutely
but uh
unfortunately as with every award show
there can only be one winner viewers
viewers get to vote their choice yeah
we'll see which one is their favorite
and honestly i have no idea why
any of these can win i have a feeling
which one might win
but we'll see okay all right and the
winner is
oh oh okay it's the jujutsu kaiser oh
okay okay okay okay wow in terms of like
animation this one is like
it's really i mean it's pretty cool the
thing that was cool about this one was
that
it like the original ending for judicial
was like
original enough and they managed to get
the style down to a team
yeah and that's what i think that's what
impressed me the most out of this one
but honestly they all impressed me
yeah honestly anyone like i feel like
out of
like we it feels weird to have to award
one of the winners because i just want
to give you all
the boys yeah they're all everyone's a
winner everyone's aware
everyone claps but uh what were the
percentages um
20 um this one was the one with
the two vote difference oh okay oh this
one was on with the two vote difference
okay so out of what 24
000 votes there's only one by two votes
oh my god wow
so what was the so what was the second
place the second one was maury gladby
oh i thought that one was gonna win yeah
that was a lot of views
yeah yeah yeah and then third fourth
fifth that was a great burger debate
with twenty two point nine zero am i
talking myself
uh fourth was how connor wakes up i love
that one
and uh in fifth place uh trashed this on
the rocks oh they're all they're all
banging they're all yeah
yeah yeah fantastic honestly fantastic
yeah but uh if you guys uh want to
submit uh animations uh then just make
sure to title your videos trash tastes
animated
so it's easier for us to find and then
yeah go ahead and animate
any moment on twitter this actual winner
i think it was like three weeks after it
was uploaded before either or
any one of us saw it right because
nobody saw it at all please at
us on twitter or at least title it trash
taste animator so it's easy for us to
find yeah but yeah keep your animations
coming we love all of them